closing the sale if you can't get your
customers to get to a close if you can't
convince them to sign on the dotted line
or hand over their visa card to you then
your business will never take off and it
doesn't matter how great a product or
service you have if you can't get them
to know about your business and sign a
deal with you your company won't take
off hi I'm Evan Carmichael I believe
that hungry entrepreneurs deserve help
and I want to share the simplest
technique that I found to close the sale
when customers are afraid they're not
going to sign up with you and that's the
biggest thing that hold people back that
hold them back from saying yes is there
fear assume when you've done all the
qualifications right they have the
budget for you they have a need for what
you're selling the thing that holds them
back is fear they're afraid that they're
going to spend too much with you they're
going to afraid that you're not going to
deliver they're afraid of trying
something new you have to make them less
afraid you have to show them away so
that their fear disappears and the
easiest method to do that it starts
small find an easy small simple
no-brainer way to get started and
working with your business don't go in
and ask for a huge order start small
start tiny make it easy for them to say
yes make it something that they could do
all on their realm they don't need to go
ask for any permission or approval it's
so dumb stupid easy for them to say yes
and start working with your business
when you get them saying yes when you
get them spending just a little bit of
money with you you start building some
momentum you start building some trust
you start building some likeability then
you over deliver like crazy you provide
outstanding service you provide
outstanding support you deliver early
instead of just being on time you over
exceed all of their expectations then
they're going to come begging to you to
do more work with you you don't have to
worry about closing future
deals is going to come the key is to
just start building that relationship
with them get them to say yes on a tiny
little project whatever that is for your
business and then blow them out of the
water with what they expected from you
compared to what you actually deliver
over deliver like crazy and you won't
have to worry about closing future deals
because they're going to come back to
you and I know what you're thinking I
want to go after these big deals I want
to lend the big fish if I have an
opportunity for this huge deal why
wouldn't I take it the problem is the
bigger the deal is the more money it is
the more they're going to be afraid the
harder it is going to be the close them
and you can still go and get these big
deals but it's way easier when you have
some kind of working relationship with
them if they're spending a little bit of
money with you and your over delivering
like crazy they love working with you
the service level is off the charts and
they compare you to the other suppliers
are working with other people they
bought from and they say hey these guys
are just they're awesome I love working
with them I have a question I call them
up they answer it then they're going to
naturally give you more and more of
their dollars the sale becomes so so so
much easier but you have to get your
foot in the door you have to get rid of
the fear that they're facing right now
it's the easiest way to get started and
i hope you apply to your business for
those of you watching if you liked the
video please give it a thumbs up below
makes want to do more for you and if you
have a comment about this video or
question for your own business I'd love
to try to answer for you I love seeing
those comments come in so thank you so
much levon below and i'll see you on the
next episode
you